Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday. So when
I was in Ethiopia, I got to talk to this young
girl, who's clinging to her brother, and I
learned that her mom went to Kuwait to work,
and her dad works in the city, so her grandpa
takes care of them.
She told me that she missed her mom and that
worried that her brother might have pneumonia,
and the way his beautiful girl held her brother
just shattered me, and eventually, I looked
away.
In fact, a lot of my footage from Ethiopia
is of me looking away; we drive up to the
hospital past families desperate to get their
loved ones good care, and I look away. I turn
the camera toward preterm babies struggling
to survive under not good enough heat lamps,
and then I turn away.
And then there was this little boy: too thin,
very sick, life-threateningly sick, with diarrhea,
who is the same age as my own son, who had
the same sweet way of getting into a chair
that's too big for him, while outside, his
mother waited nervously for a diagnosis, for
some help, and I looked away. While she waited
to find out if he had malaria, I filmed this
beautiful vista.
Now I think this was partly because even though
these people all gave me permission to film
them, these moments felt very private. But
it was also hard to watch, it's hard to see
kids suffer, and mothers worry, and to feel
powerless before it, and it's hard because
these are problems that I was unaccustomed
to, I mean the poor are voiceless in too much
of our contemporary discourse. This kid's
mom doesn't have a Twitter or a Youtube channel.
And so we don't hear about her challenges
as directly as we hear about others. Maybe
that's part of what makes it easier to look
away too, but regardless, I kept doing it;
I have hours of footage of my camera looking
away. I spent all this time in Ethiopia, and
what I videotaped most was my shoes.
I've talked before about how much there is
to be excited about in Ethiopia - child death
has dropped by more than two thirds in 20
years, and that's amazing! As is the huge
growth in school attendance rates, and the
growing number of college graduates.
But Ethiopia is still one of the poorest countries
in the world. Malnutrition is common, and
almost half of Ethiopians don't have access
to clean water, which is probably why that
boy was so sick in the first place.
So I understand this urge to look away, but
I think to change the world, we must grapple
with it as we find it. I wanna live in a world
where children don't die of diarrhea and malaria,
where they aren't malnourished, where they
can drink clean water. And the world I want
to live in won't come about by me looking
away.
The problem, Hank, is that if we only look
away, it's hard to listen, and it is through
listening that we can learn how to actually
help, rather than just imposing upon others
OUR ideas for what they need.
This woman - a member of the women's health
army - told me that she has to walk miles
twice a week to fill jerrycans with drinking
water, and dirty river water is used for washing.
When I asked her what her community needed
most, she answered immediately: water.
Healthcare worker Abd Al-Kadir said the same,
explaining that it was hard to deliver babies
without water to keep everyone clean. This
healthcare outpost worker, these women, this
grandfather -- they all cited water as among
their most basic needs.
So okay, let's not look away, let's listen.
I talked to water.org and they set up a fundraiser
for the nerdfighter community. All the money
raised will go towards sustainable water solutions
for people in Ethiopia, and if raise a $100,000
in the next 10 days, Bill Gates will personally
match our donation, so every dollar we donate
will count as two, and if reach our goal we
can get safe water to 8,000 people.
Now that's not a solution, Hank. It's not
gonna end poverty or childhood mortality,
but it CAN change the lives of those 8,000
people, so if you can donate, please do at
water.org/johngreen. There's also a link in
the dooblydoo.
Hank, here's to trying to learn to listen,
and not to look away. I'll see you on Friday.